my mom has always reminded me that I
have the same proportions as a lego man
and she does actually have a point and
Lego is a company that has succeeded in
making everybody believe that Lego is
from their home country but it's not
it's from my home country so you can
imagine my excitement when the lego
family called me and asked us to work
with them to design the home of the
brick this is the architectural model we
build a lot of Lego obviously this is
the final result and what we tried to do
was to design a building that would be
as interactive and as engaging and as
playful as Lego is itself with these
kind of interconnected playgrounds on
the roof scape you can enter a square on
the ground where the citizens of Berlin
can roam around freely without a ticket
and it's probably one of the only
museums in the world where you're
allowed to touch all the artifacts that
the Danish word for design is form
giving which literally means to give
form to that which has not yet been
given form in other words to give form
to the future and what I love about Lego
is that Lego is not a toy it's a tool
that empowers the child to build his or
her own world and then to inhabit that
world through Play and to invite her
friends to join her in cohabiting and
co-creating that world and that is
exactly what form giving is as human
beings we have the power to give form to
our future inspired by Lego we've built
a social housing project in Copenhagen
where we've stacked blocks of wood next
to each other between them they leave
spaces with extra ceiling heights and
balconies and and by gently wiggling the
blocks we can actually create curves or
any organic form adapting to any urban
context because adaptable
is probably one of the strongest drivers
of architecture
another example is here in Vancouver we
were asked to look at this site where
Granville bridge try folks as it touches
downtown and we started like mapping the
different constraints there's like a
hundred foot setback from the bridge
because the city wants to make sure that
no one looks into the traffic on the
bridge there's a park where we can't
cast any shadows so finally we're left
with a tiny triangular footprint almost
too small to build but let me thought
like what if the hundred foot minimum
distance is really about minimum
distance once we get a hundred feet up
in the air we can grow the building back
out and and so we did when you drive
over the bridge it's as if someone is
pulling a curtain aback welcoming you to
Vancouver or like a weed growing through
the cracks in the pavement and
blossoming as it gets light and air
underneath the bridge we've worked with
Rodney gray hem and a handful of
Vancouver artists to create what we
called the Sistine Chapel of street art
an art gallery turned upside down that
tries to turn the negative impact of the
bridge into a positive so even if it
looks like this kind of surreal
architecture it's highly adapted to its
surroundings
so if a bridge can become a museum a
museum can also serve as a bridge in
Norway we're building a museum that
spans across a river and allow people to
sort of journey through the exhibitions
as they cross from one side of a
sculpture park to the other an
architecture sort of adapted to its
landscape in China we built the
headquarters for an energy company and
we designed the facade like an EC Miyake
fabric it's rippled so that facing the
predominant direction of the Sun it's
all opaque facing away from the Sun it's
all glass on average it's sort of
transitions from solid to clear and this
very simple idea without any moving
parts or any sort of technology purely
because of the geometry of the facade it
reduces the energy consumption on
cooling with 30 percent so you can say
what makes the building look elegant is
also
what makes it perform elegantly it's an
architecture that is adapted to its
climate you can also adapt you know one
culture to another like we took in
Manhattan we took the Copenhagen
courtyard building with the social space
where people can hang out in this kind
of ways this in the middle of city and
we combined it with the density and the
verticality of an American skyscraper
creating what we've called a quartz
creeper from New York to Copenhagen
on the waterfront of Copenhagen we are
right now finishing this waste-to-energy
power plant it's going to be the
cleanest waste-to-energy power plant in
the world there are no toxins coming out
of the chimney an amazing marvel of
engineering that is completely invisible
so we thought how can we express this
and in in Copenhagen we have snow as you
can see but we have absolutely no
mountains we have to go six hours by bus
to get to Sweden to get Alpine Skiing
so we thought let's put an alpine ski
slope on the roof of the power plant so
this is the this is the first test run
we did a few months ago and what I like
about this is that it also shows you the
sort of world changing power of form
giving I have a five month old son and
and he's going to grow up in a world not
knowing that there was ever a time when
you couldn't ski on the roof of the
power plants so
so imagine for him and his generation
that's their baseline imagine how far
they can leap what kind of wild ideas
they can put forward for their future so
right in front of it we're building our
smallest project it's basically nine
containers that we have stacked in a
shipyard in Poland then we've slept it
across the Baltic Sea and ducted in the
Port of Copenhagen where it is now the
home of 12 students each student has
like a view to the water they can jump
out the window into the clean port of
Copenhagen and they can get back in all
the heat comes from the thermal mass of
the sea all the power comes from the Sun
this is the first 12 units in Copenhagen
another 60 on their way another 200 are
going to Gothenburg and we're speaking
with the Paris Olympics to put a small
floating village on the sin so very much
this kind of almost like nomadic
impermanent architecture and the
waterfronts of our cities are
experiencing a lot of change economic
change industrial change and climate
change this is Manhattan before
Hurricane sandy and this is Manhattan
after sandy we got invited by the city
of New York to look if we could make the
necessary flood protection for Manhattan
without building a seawall that would
segregate the life of the city from the
water around it and we got inspired by
the High Line you probably know the High
Line it's this amazing new Park in New
York
it's basically decommissioned train
tracks that now have become one of the
most popular promenades in the city so
we thought could we design the necessary
flood protection for Manhattan so we
don't have to wait until we shut it down
before it gets nice so we sat down with
with the citizens living along the
waterfront of New York and we work with
them to try to design the necessary
flood protection in such a way that it
only makes their waterfront more
accessible and more enjoyable underneath
the FDR we're putting like pavilions
with pocket walls that can slide out and
to take from the water we're creating
little stepped terraces that are going
to make the
on the side more enjoyable but also is
going to protect from from flooding for
the north in the in the East River Park
we are creating rolling hills that that
protect the park from the noise of the
highway but in turn also become the
necessary flood protection that can stop
the waves during an incoming storm surge
so in a way this project that we have
called the dry line it's essentially the
High Line that the High Line that's
going to keep Manhattan dry it's it's
scheduled to break ground on the first
East River portion at the end of this
year but it has essentially been
co-designed with the citizens of lower
Manhattan to sort of take all of the
necessary infrastructure for resilience
and give it positive social and
environmental side effects so New York
is not alone in facing this this
situation in fact by 2050 ninety percent
of the major cities in the world are
going to be dealing with with rising
seas in Hamburg they've created a whole
neighborhood where the bottom floors are
designed to withstand the inevitable
flood in Sweden they've designed a city
where all of the parks are sort of wet
gardens designed to deal with storm
water and and waste water so we thought
could we perhaps actually today three
million people are already permanently
living on the sea so we thought could we
actually imagine a floating city
designed to incorporate all of the
sustainable development goals of the
United Nations into a sort of a whole
new human-made ecosystem and of course
we have to design it so it can produce
its own power harvesting the thermal
mass of the oceans the force of the
tides of the currents of the waves the
power of the wind the heat and the and
the energy of the Sun also we're going
to collect all of the rainwater that
drops on this like man-made archipelago
and deal with it organically and
and mechanically and store it and clean
it we have to grow all of our food
locally it has to be fish and
plant-based because you won't have the
space or the resources for for dairy
diet and and finally we're gonna deal
with all the waste locally with with
compost recycling and turning the waste
into into energy so imagine where a
traditional urban master plan you
typically draw the street grid where the
cars can drive and the sort of building
plots where you can put some buildings
this master plan we sat down with a
handful of scientists and basically
started with all of the renewable
available natural resources and then we
started channeling the flow of resources
through this kind of human-made
ecosystem or this kind of urban
metabolism so it's a it's going to be
modular it's going to be buoyant it's
going to be designed to resist a
tropical storm
you can pre fabricate it at scale and
tow it into to dock with others to form
a small community we're designing these
kind of coastal additions so that even
if it's modular and rational each Island
can be unique with its own coastal
landscape the architecture has to remain
sort of relatively low to keep the the
sense of gravity buoyant we're going to
take all of the agriculture and use it
to also create social space so you can
actually enjoy the permaculture Gardens
we're designing it for the tropics so
all of the roofs are maximized to have a
solar power and to shade from the Sun
all the materials are going to be light
and renewable like bamboo and wood which
is also going to create this kind of
charming a warm environment and any
architecture is supposed to be able to
fit on on this on this platform
underneath we have all the storage like
inside the pontoon almost like a mega
version of the student house things that
we've already worked with we have all
the storage for the energy that's
produced all of the water storage and
and remediation we sort of dealing with
all of the the waist and the composting
and we also have some backup farming
with aeroponics and
and hydroponics so imagine almost like a
vertical section through this landscape
that goes from the air above where we
have vertical farms below we have the
aeroponics and the and the aquaponics
even further below we have the ocean
farms and where we tie the island to the
ground we're using bio rock to create
new reefs to regenerate habitat so so
think of this kind of small island for
300 people it can then groove together
to form a cluster or a neighborhood that
then can sort of group together to form
an entire city for 10,000 people and you
can imagine if this floating city
flourishes it can sort of grow like a
culture in a petri dish so one of the
first places we're looking at placing
this or anchoring this floating city is
in the Pearl River Delta so imagine this
kind of canopy of photovoltaics on this
archipelago floating in in the sea as
you sort of sail towards the island
you'll see the maritime residents moving
around on alternative forms of aquatic
transportation you come into this kind
of community port you can roam around in
the permaculture gardens that are
productive landscapes but also social
landscapes the greenhouses also become
orange lease for the cultural life of
the city and below under the sea it's
teeming with life of farming and science
and and social spaces so so in a way you
can imagine this kind of community port
is where people gather both by by day
and by night and and even if the first
one is designed for the tropics we also
imagine that the architecture can adapt
to any culture so imagine like a Middle
Eastern floating city or Southeast Asian
floating city or maybe a Scandinavian
floating city one day so maybe just to
to conclude the human body is 70% water
and the surface of our planet is 70%
water and it's rising and even if the
whole world woke up tomorrow and became
carbon neutral overnight there are still
island nations that are destined
to sink in the seas unless we also
develop alternate forms of floating
human habitats and the only constant in
the universe is change our world is
always changing and right now our
climate is changing no matter how
critical the crisis is and it is this is
also our collective human superpower
that we have the power to adapt to
change and we have the power to give
form to our future
[Applause]